- Practice faithful persistence
means never ever ever give up.
I mean how many of you
have ever had a great idea,
talked about it, thought
about it, didn't do it
and then someone else did it.
And was successful
and you went darn I should have done that.
you know one of the greatest myths
that's pervasive in our culture today
is that you're entitled to a great life.
If you're not experiencing joy
as you as you think about doing something
and as you pursue doing it
then it's off course for you.
- He's an American author,
motivational speaker, corporate trainer
and entrepreneur.
He's the co-author
of the Chicken Soup for the Soul series
that has sold over five
hundred million copies
in 40 languages.
In 2005 he co-authored
the success principles
How to Get from Where You Are
to Where you Want to Be.
He's Jack Canfield
and here is my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite.
I'm curious to find out
which one you guys like the best.
also as you're watching the video
if you hear something that Jack says
that really resonates with you
add it to the comments with quotes
so we can keep track
of what you find most relevant.
- Practice faithful persistence
means never ever ever give up.
Chicken Soup for the Soul
was rejected by 144 publishers.
144 publisher said
we don't want to publish
a collection of short stories.
The title's stupid
Chicken Soup for the Soul.
What does that mean?
People don't buy collections
of short stories.
There's never been you know successful
chain of doing that.
So literally we spent 14 months
trying to find a publisher
and we go to New York with our agent
and eventually our agent
gave us the book back
and said I can't sell this.
So we went
to the National Booksellers Association
convention down in Anaheim.
We went from booth to booth to booth
for three days.
And there were 4,000
publishers represented there
and we go would you publish our book?
Would you publish our book?
And we got no, no, no, no, no.
It was late on the third day
that a little publisher from Florida
after we'd gotten over 144 rejections
said we'll read it
and then we said well how many copies
do you think we'll sell
after they said yeah we'll buy it.
A couple weeks later he
said we'll publish it.
And they said well maybe
20,000 if we're lucky.
Now we said our goal is to sell a million
and a half in a year and a half.
Now have you ever told someone your dream
and had them laugh out loud at you?
(audience laughs)
He laughed out loud.
Now if we had given up
after a hundred publishers had said no
I wouldn't be standing here today.
You know, wouldn't have happened.
And so you've got to
be willing to persevere
because we didn't take no.
See when the world says no
you say next.
Let's practice that if I say no you say...
- [Audience] Next.
- Absolutely there's only five
or six billion people out there.
You can go and ask right.
There's over four thousand publishers
just here in the state of California.
So what we have is this
endless possibility
but you have to persevere.
It's as if the universe
tests our commitment.
And so today we have 147 titles in print.
We sold over 115 million copies.
We're in 47 languages
and over a billion dollars worth
of Chicken Soup for the Soul books
have been sold worldwide.
So if you're willing to
decide what you want,
believe it's possible,
consciously envision the future,
feel the feelings of
what it would feel like
if you'd achieve this goal.
You can have anything
and then you take action
both obvious actions
and inspired actions.
You can do anything.
One of the functions of belief
is taking action.
We did a survey of about
2,000 top entrepreneurs
and we noticed that one of the things
that people who win in that world have
is a bias for action.
If they have an
inspiration they act on it.
I mean how many of you
have ever had a great idea,
talked about it, thought
about it, didn't do it
and then someone else did it.
And was successful
and you went darn I should have done that.
Maybe it was by that piece of property.
We all have that piece of property
we wish we'd bought you know.
Anyway so we're going to be looking at
the idea that taking action
is part of the Law of Attraction.
See a lot of people think
you just sit in your room,
meditate, visualize,
having the perfect car, the perfect house,
the perfect relationship
and then it'll kind of just come to you.
And I always say
unless you live at the bottom of the hill
(audience laughs)
where there's a road
there's probably not
going to be a Cadillac
show up in your living room right.
So think about this.
The last six letters
of the word attraction spell what?
A, C, T, I, O, N, action.
Now there's two kinds of actions
that are critical.
There's obvious actions.
If you want a certain kind of car
you should go down and test drive it.
You should find out how much it costs.
You should see what it
costs to maintain it.
You should go you know spend...
I like to test drive a
car three or four times
go down to the dealer,
take a camera,
stick my head out the window.
Say take a picture of me.
(audience laughs)
I'll be back to buy it.
Put it up on my refrigerator.
Look at it every day.
Eventually you know
those kind of things produce car.
Right saving for it and so forth
but there are also things
called inspired actions.
All of a sudden you get an inspiration
to do something
and you didn't know what it was.
You don't have a sense
of like how's this rationally
going to make sense
for me to move forward in my life.
I'll give you an example a friend of mine
Dr. Ignatius Piazza
graduates chiropractic school.
He wants to move to
Monterrey near Pebble Beach
where the golf course is
and he gets there
and he says to the local
Chiropractic Association
like to join you,
and like you to help me
get my practice started.
And they said
we don't need any more chiropractors.
We have one chiropractor
for every eight people in this area.
It's too many.
Now he could have said okay
let the external reality control
his internal experience.
But he doesn't do that he said
I'm going to think about this
and visualize it and believe in it
and something will come that I will do.
And what came to him to do
was to take six months
before he opened his office
and put a pin where he wanted his office
and then concentric circles
knock on every door in every neighborhood
saying Hi I'm a new doctor in town
could I ask you a few questions.
You know I'm starting this practice
should I open from 5:00
to 9:00 in the morning
and or should I be open
from 5:00 until 9:00 at night
for people who have nine-to-five jobs.
Which would be better?
Should I advertise in this paper
or that paper?
Should I call it Ignatius
Piazza chiropractic
or chiropractic West?
Then his last question was
if I have an open house
would you like to receive an invitation?
They said yes.
He wrote it down.
Now over six months he knocked
on 12,500 doors,
talk to 6,500 people
and gathered over 4,000 names
of people who said yes
I'd like an invitation to your open house.
Now when he opened his
office six months later
in a town that did not need
another chiropractor according
to the professionals
his first month in practice
he netted $72,000.
In his first year in practice
his gross income was
over a million dollars.
I was giving a talk
and mentioned this story
just about five years ago
and this happened about 25 years ago.
Someone said he knocked on my door.
(audience laughs)
And he left his card
and two years later I
needed the chiropractor
and I called him
because we work with people we know,
we've had an experience with right.
So he trusted his intuition.
He took action on it.
Other people would say
oh if I can't have what I want.
You got to be willing to take the action.
If you're going to be successful
in creating the life of your dreams
you have to believe that
you are capable of making it happen.
You have to believe that
you have the right stuff
and that you're able to pull it off.
Now whether you call it self-esteem,
self-confidence or self assurance,
it's a deep-seated belief
that you have what it takes,
the abilities, the inner resources,
the talents and the skills
to create your desired results.
Now believing in yourself
is simply an attitude.
Believing yourself is a choice.
You have to choose to believe
that you can do anything
you set your mind to.
Anything at all
because in fact you can.
It might help you to know
that the latest brain
research now indicates
with enough positive self-talk
and positive visualization
combined with proper training, coaching,
and practice anyone can learn
to do almost anything.
Now I've interviewed thousands
of successful people
and almost every one of them
has told me I was not the most gifted
or the most talented person in my field
but I chose to believe
that anything was possible.
And because of that I studied,
I practiced and I worked harder
than the others
and that's how I got to where I am.
You know if Ruben Gonzalez,
a 20 year old living in Texas,
hot Texas can pick up the luge
which is a winter sport
and become an Olympic athlete,
if Bill Gates who is a college dropout
can become a multi-billionaire
and Stephen Jay Cannel
who was a dyslexic student
who failed three grades in school
can become a best-selling author
and a television producer
then you too can accomplish anything
if you'll simply believe it's possible.
So make the decision right now
to believe that you create
all of your experiences
because you do.
Let's start creating the ones you want
by believing you can.
Sounds a little strange
but accepting this level of responsibility
is uniquely and inevitably empowering.
It means you can do, change
and become anything at all.
You may think that something as small
as being optimistic
won't change much about your life.
Have you ever heard this line?
Just because I'm paranoid
doesn't mean the world
isn't out to get me.
Now that may be a joke
but many people believe
the deck is stacked against them.
People who are reverse paranoids
otherwise known as optimists
use the same consistent thinking
but they believe that
the world is plotting
to do them good.
Everything that happens is pushing them
in the right direction.
This attitude breeds more good thoughts
so why not practice
to become a reverse paranoid?
Start seeing obstacles as opportunities
to grow and change.
When your presentation
doesn't get the sale
see it as an opportunity
to create a better presentation
and become better at your job.
See the task
that gives you some power
to change rather than the fear
that makes you feel powerless.
Look for the seed of something better
when everything is going wrong.
Almost everyone sees getting laid off
as a bad thing but even
if you want your job to be over
the end always feel sad and uninspiring.
The end of one job however
always holds the promise
of the new beginning,
of the next job.
If you look at it that way
you're focusing on what
a reverse paranoid thinks about.
Identify the great benefit in every event.
Soon you'll start to see
that good is not an accident
but something you create
with your attitudes.
Walk through your home,
your business, your apartment,
your condo, anything you're in charge of
and make a list of all the things
that aren't exactly the way you wanted.
There's never a stapler
by the Xerox machine.
Someone always leaves that cabinet open.
My kid never picks up after himself.
Those pictures are always slanted.
They never stay straight.
The screen door slams.
There's a hole in the window.
You know whatever it is write it down
and then go back
and here's the key part.
Remember in law of attraction
we always it's on what you want
not what you don't want.
You don't want to be going
I don't want a man who smokes.
I don't want a man who
watches TV all weekend.
I don't want a man who...
(audience laughs)
Because that's what you're going to get.
Alright because what you focus on
is what you attract.
So you want to focus on the opposite.
So what you want to focus on
is the opposite of your irritation list.
There'll always be a stapler
by the Xerox machine.
We solved it in our
office with a little chain
and some glue.
(audience laughs)
It doesn't leave, okay.
But the key is there's always solutions.
The pictures that won't stay straight.
Velcro right to the wall.
Go on the bottom.
It works you know
but the point is
you want to get a list
of what's the outcome you want
and then take a day
hire person or you know
bring a friend over
and go through the list
and get as many done as you can.
You know all the easy ones.
Build some momentum.
Clean the garage.
Develop a new filing system.
That might be something you'd you know
set off to another weekend.
And we say all the big ones
that are really big
do one a quarter every, three months,
solve one of those.
Now you're getting rid of
all the stuff in your life
and why is this so important.
We're talking mostly about being wealthy,
having great relationships,
great health, world peace, ending hunger,
and you're talking about the screen door.
When you don't fix the screen door
you settle.
And when you settle consistently
you develop a habit of settling
for what you don't want.
And most people go through
life in resignation.
They've resigned themselves
to not having it the way they want it.
It's taking no less
than 100% responsibility
for your life.
You know one of the greatest myths
that's pervasive in our culture today
is that you're entitled to a great life
and then somehow somewhere someone
is responsible for filling our lives
with continual happiness
and exciting career options,
a nurturing family
and blissful personal relationships
simply because we exist
but the real truth is
that there's only one person responsible
for the quality of your life
and that person is you.
You see everything about you
is a result of your doing or not doing.
Your income, your debt,
your relationships,
your health, your fitness
level, your attitudes
and behaviors, everything.
That person you see
when you look in the mirror
is the chief architect in your life.
You know I think everybody knows this
in their heart of hearts
but the mind can play games
tricking us into thinking
that there are external factors
that are the source of our failures,
our disappointments and our unhappiness.
But the truth of the matter
is that external factors
don't determine how you live.
You and only you are
in complete control of the quality
of your life experience.
Successful people take full responsibility
for the thoughts they think,
the images they visualize
and the actions they take.
They don't waste their time
and energy on blaming and complaining.
They evaluate their experiences
and decide if they need
to change them or not.
They face the uncomfortable
and they take risks
in order to create the life
that they want to live.
How many of you
have ever complained in your life?
(audience laughs)
Yeah you know.
Here's what I've learned
about complaining.
In order to complain
I have to have a reference point
of something better that I want
that I'm not willing to risk creating.
Now let me explain that again.
I have to have a
reference point in my mind
of something I want
that's better than what I have
that I'm not willing to risk creating.
So what I do is complain about it instead.
See if I was complaining about my wife
it would mean that I would have to believe
that somewhere out there in the world
there's a better woman than my wife.
See if every woman on the planet died
except my wife
do you think I'd go to work the next day
and complain about her?
(audience laughs)
No, she's the only one.
And I'd be going hey and I got her.
This is really cool right?
(audience laughs)
Do you ever hear anyone
complain about gravity?
(audience laughs)
Very rarely.
You know gravity makes us all bent over.
Do you ever see an old person
walking down a street going,
gravity.
They have a little walker.
I hate gravity.
(audience laughs)
If it weren't for gravity
I wouldn't be all bent over like this.
Gravity sucks.
(audience laughs)
Now have you ever heard
an older person doing that?
No, the reason they don't
complain about gravity
is because there's no alternative to it.
You know gravity just is.
So if someone's
complaining about something
it means they know
there's something they can do about it
because we don't complain
about the things we can't change.
So as soon as you hear
yourself complaining
I want you to stop
and say okay what would I rather have?
remember Law of Attraction
always just focus on what you want
not what you don't want
because when you're talking about
what you don't want,
when you're complaining and blaming
you're focusing on
that which you don't want
and you're accelerating its expression
out into the universe
with those negative feelings.
And yet we'll spend a majority
of our time complaining
about so many things.
And usually we complain about them
to people who can't do anything about it.
Make a list of 101 things
you want to achieve before you die.
Now I was sharing this
with someone last night.
He said God that just seems
like a really big task.
I'm a single mom.
I don't have any time.
When am I going to do that?
(audience laughs)
We know that one of the things
about high achievers
is that they all have goals.
Only 10% of Americans
set goals every year.
10%.
I go to sales confrences,
people that learn this stuff,
hear it over and over.
How many?
10%.
We also know the same three
to 10% control 90% of the
resources in the world.
So literally without goals
you're directionless.
You will be used.
See people without goals
get used by other people who have them.
People that don't have goals
work for people who do.
And so you want to be someone
who picks up and gets clear
about what you want.
Make a list.
101 goals.
I want to go to Paris.
I want to you know skydive.
I want to bungee cord jump.
I want to play the guitar.
I want to learn to juggle.
I want to learn two magic
tricks for the kids.
I want to go to the Olympics in Beijing.
Whatever it is make the list.
And you'll see there's a
lot of stuff under there
that you've kind of put down that you want
and you can have anything you want.
If you want to know how to decide
if a career opportunity is a good one
there are several things
you have to take into consideration.
Number one, does it make your heart sing.
The number one feedback system
that you are given at birth is joy.
If you're not experiencing joy
as you as you think about doing something
and as you pursue doing it
then it's off course for you.
You also want to put your
rational mind to work.
You want to some due diligence.
Ask other people
who've gone down that road before.
What was it like?
What did they have to do?
What were some of the costs of that path?
What were some of the pay offs
and the benefits?
And really get a sense
of what it would be like to do that.
Sometimes you can go
and do an internship
or you can work for a
friend in their restaurant
just to see if you like it
because often the fantasy
doesn't match the reality.
And the other thing is
to simply trust yourself.
You know deep inside what's true for you
and if you'll take a few minutes
and go inside, we call it meditation,
and just ask and sit with the question
and see what kind of feelings come up.
Does this feel right?
So do all the rational research
but then ultimately bring it back
into your heart and decide
does this feel good for me?
And if it makes sense up here
and it feels good
then step into it.
Just lean into it and see what happens.
Pursue it.
No decision is forever.
You can always change
if it's not what you want.
When you're a kid
you have an impulse to act, you act.
You want to touch the cat,
you want to throw the cat out the window,
you want to stick your hand into the VCR,
and put peanut butter in there, you do.
The problem is
as we're growing up
we get conditioned by our parents
and our caretakers and our siblings
and our teachers and coaches
and nuns and all these different people
that come into our life,
don't do that.
Stop, that's bad.
You know we get slapped
and told we're not OK.
And so after a while
when we go to do something
we're looking, is it ok if I do this.
You know instead of just doing it.
All my sons and my stepson
and my stepdaughter
have been great risk takers.
They're all artists.
One's a drummer.
One's a hip-hop singer.
One is in high school
but he's in the school play.
He just had to lead in the school play.
He's a singer.
And then my daughter's a singer
and my other son is very athletic.
He's a surfer.
He snow boards as well
and he's always inventing games
and trying out new things.
Always on the edge you know.
Always coming in with cuts and scrapes
which I love
because they're out there on the edge
of their potential, exploring
how they can keep pushing it.
And it's not that they never get scared
or they never feel rejected
and have to go through things.
But they seem to rebound very quickly.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I made this video
because Narup Malkain asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
you want me to profile next
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know
which of Jack's ten messages
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What change you're going
to make in your life
or business after watching this video.
Leave it in the comments
and I will join the discussion.
Also if you see some of the quotes
that people have left from Jack
from these clips
and you really resonate with them
make sure to give them a thumbs up
and show some love.
Finally want to give a quick shout out
to Farbod from powercharge.com.
Farbod thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book.
It really means a lot to me.
Those of you watching,
if you want your chance at a shoutout
in a future video
make sure to grab a copy of the book
and then email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe
or whatever your one word is
and I'll see you soon.
- The other thing,
a friend of mine just wrote a book
called The Fear Cure or the Cure for fear,
one of those.
And she talked about
one of the biggest fears
is of the unknown and
uncertainty of the future
but everything is uncertain.
You know we're trying to create certainty
in an uncertain world
and stop being afraid of uncertainty.
Uncertainty is what's exciting.
You go to Africa on a vacation, a safari.
You've no idea what's going to happen.
That's part of the adventure.
- It's fun.
- That's part of the fun exactly.
- If you knew all there's
going to be a zebra
that pops out right here
or this is going to be next
that would be boring right.
- Or if you go river rafting
you don't know where the rapids are
and how you're going to do it
and if you go surfing
you don't know exactly how the wave
is going to break and all that
and how big it's going to be.
And so that adventure is
really what life's about
and so we need to be excited.
Fear is created by imagining bad things
that haven't happened yet.
So fantasized experiences appearing real.
Everyone always says that.
Someone else recently said
forget everything and run.
But I think that if you realize
that you're creating your own fear
by imagining a bad thing,
of if there's a recession
I'll lose my house.
Why not go if there was a recession
I'm going to make more money
because there's going to be opportunities
and we're going to be able
to pay our house out faster.
Zig Ziglar said worrying
is negative goal-setting
and all you have to do
is use that same power to think
and visualize to create a positive outcome
instead of a negative
and then the fear disappears.
Let's look at this idea
of specificity for a minute.
Like a winter home in Hawaii.
Very nice
but if I say I will own
a two-bedroom beachfront villa
on the west coast of Maui Hawaii
by June 1st 2003
does that sound a little more clear?
Yeah and until you get specific like that
the creative part of your brain
won't jump in
and decide how to help you get there.
And that's why a lot of people
never get their dreams
because they don't make
them specific enough.
You got to get real nitty-gritty.
Break it down.
How much buy when?
I want a better relationship
with my husband.
What does that mean?
But if I say I want to
spend an hour a week
sitting opposite my husband
talking about real things that matter,
no TV on,
eye to eye communication,
well that we can measure.
Did you do it for an hour?
Want to have more fun.
What does that mean?
Well, what if I say I'm going to listen
to comedy albums twice a week
for a minimum of an hour.
You're probably going to have more fun.
So make it specific make it.
Make it real.
Some people say you know
I want our business to increase.
Well how much by when?
Want the reading scores
to go up in a school.
How much, by when?
Until you have that
you're not going to make progress
and so many people's dreams
never get completed
because they're not clear
about the specific number
of how much by when.
I told you earlier in the program.
We said we're going to sell a million
and a half books in a year and a half
and that directed our behavior.
Recently we just said
we're going to sell a
million books in one day.
We had 101 bookstores
involved in a book signing.
I'm going to try to be
in the Guinness Book of World Records
for the largest book signing ever done.
Now I don't think we sold a million books.
Maybe we sold
a couple hundred thousand
but by holding that question
and trying to figure out how to do it
it moved us toward that goal.
Now maybe it'll take us two years
to figure out how to sell a million books
in one day
but it gets the thinking
to expand out into that arena.
Is this making sense?
Okay so you want to have those goals.
Now the other thing you want to do
is break your goals down.
Many of you have big goals,
end hunger in the world.
That's a pretty big goal.
You know have world peace.
Achieve a certain level
of spiritual oneness
with God or life.
Big goals.
When you first look at
it's kind of overwhelming
but what if we were to break that down
into little steps
that says okay I want to go to college
and get a PhD.
Gosh I'm only a high school student
but the next step would be
finish the math class.
Get an A in this.
Write for a brochure from a college.
Get a catalog.
Pick one or five colleges
that I want to apply to.
You know just keep breaking it down
to little steps and then figure out
how to get all those steps done
and put a date by each step.
And then start doing the plan.
Someone said if you fail to plan
you're planning to fail.
Does that make sense?
Yeah absolutely.
Some of one of my friends
said success by the yard is hard
by the inch it's a cinch.
So we just break it
down into small pieces.
I had I was reading
the Guinness Book of World Records
cause we were thinking
about being in there
and this guy set a goal
to eat an entire bicycle.
(audience gasps)
Tires and all.
Now how do you do that?
right well it took him 17 days
but what he did is
he kept cutting the bicycle up
and then melting it down
into little swallowable pieces
and he ate them.
I don't know how much stayed in
but he ate them right?
But the point being
anything can be done
if you break it down small enough.
Make sense?
So don't let the bigness
of a goal overwhelm you.
Now I was over in Bangkok.
How many of you've been
to Bangkok Thailand.
How many of you have
seen the Golden Buddha?
It's one of the three tourist attractions.
You always see the Jade Buddha,
the Golden Buddha and the Reclining Buddha
and that kind of thing
and this Buddha is 10
and a half feet tall of solid gold.
The gold value alone is
about 196 million dollars.
That doesn't even count the artistic
and the historical value.
And when my wife was taking that picture
I was over next to the
I'd say about five feet away
there was a big glass case
and in that case
there was a piece of clay
about a foot wide, two
feet tall, two feet thick
and it said that in 1953
they did not know there was such a thing
as a Golden Buddha.
They were moving this large clay Buddha
from one side of Bangkok
to the other to make room for a
road that was coming through.
And as they picked up the Buddha
with the crane because it was very heavy
a big crack went down through it.
And as the crack went down through it
the head monk got scared
and he lowered the Buddha down.
And he said you know we'd better
take a look at it and see
if we've done any damage to it
and it started to rain
so they put a canvas over it
to keep it dry.
That night the monk came out
and he shined a flashlight in
to see if we was staying dry
and something reflected back
from inside the crack.
He said clay does not reflect light.
There must be something else in there.
And so the next morning
they chipped away in behind
where they wouldn't see it
if they've made a mistake
and lo and behold
sure enough was this Golden Buddha.
And their best theory is
that three hundred years earlier
when the Burmese were attacking Thailand
the monks of this monastery
covered up the Golden Buddha
with clay to make it look worthless
so they wouldn't steal it.
They also think all the monks were killed
in a massacre
and the secret died with the monks.
And then they'd rediscovered it.
The word discover means what?
Take the cover off of.
Discover something.
It was always in there
but they took the cover off.
I was having dinner
with my wife that night
and she said
you know Jack that Buddha
is like all the people in our seminars.
They come in with this cover of clay
of their negative beliefs,
their self-doubt, their sense
of guilt and shame, their beliefs
that they're not enough,
that they're not worthy,
they don't deserve and
and what we really do
is we take the clay off
so this golden essence can come
and be there as who they are again.
They're true identity.
It's not like we put anything in.
It's just that we remove the things
that are not there.
I think Barbara talked a little
about that earlier today.
So as we go through this
next hour and a half
think about and hold that metaphor.
That image of the Buddha
and it could be the golden Christ,
the Golden Buddha, the Atman,
the source, whatever you want to call it,
but that's who you really are.
And although we do
a lot of things of giving
you more information
and tools and all of that
really if you were to stop
doing the stuff that's negative
as Harp said you've been defined,
when you came in you were just fine,
and what we did was we layered
on all that stuff.
If we could just start to remove that
and realize that everything you need
is in you now.
You have everything you need
to do everything you want to do.
It's just that we've
learned not to trust that.